>>Eric: I wanted to put the image of the cover
of my book up here to begin the talk, yes,
partly for promotional reasons, uh, I confess,
but also because I want you to pay attention
to a couple things on the cover image, it
was not easy to come up with.
Um, and the two really important things to
note here, first is just the title of the
book, which is called Going Solo.
And, for much of the project, when I was doing
the research and writing it, the title I was
working with was called Alone in America.
And I just want you think about the place
that Alone in America, as a title, takes you
to, as opposed to Going Solo, takes you to
a very different place.
And the other thing I want you to pay attention
to is, the birds.
Uh, because it turns out that when you have
a title like Alone in America, you think of
another set of images, you have a cassette
of stock images in your mind already and I
think I know what they are.
I want to show them to you later and see if
you agree.
Um, the birds are not those images, so keep
this in mind.
What I want to do over the next forty minutes
or so is persuade you of two big ideas.
Uh the first is this one and I'm not going
to insult you by reading them to you, I'm
guessing that you guys read slides.
One of my pet peeves is people who come and
give PowerPoint presentations and read you
slides.
Um, you can do that on your own, but this
is the first big idea.
Um and this is the second one.
It doesn't mean what we think.
Now, I'm presuming you think something and
that might not be fair, but when I asked you
if you had an image for Alone in America,
I'm guessing it's one of either of the two
images I'm about to show you.
You might have thought of a guy like this,
the kind of Lone Ranger, frontier character.
Uh an iconic figure in American culture and
you would have good reason.
It turns out until about the 1950s living
alone in the United States was most prevalent
in the big open sprawling western states,
places like Alaska and Wyoming and Montana.
These were largely migrant working men and
in my fantasies, they look like this.
They're lone ranger kinds of guys.
But we're in New York City and I, you know,
trust that you're urbanists and so when we
in New York City think of what it is to live
alone or to be alone we often times think
of this image here.
This is Ed Hopper's 'Nighthawks', a 1943 painting.
And there many things that could be said about
this image.
It's you know, also one of the great icons
of American culture.
But what's typically said about it is, this
is a depiction of profound loneliness.
And we can see it in many ways.
If you look, for instance at the man whose
back is towards us, you know what's notable
about him is that he's by himself and it's
night.
Now it's interesting to me, we actually don't
see his face, he might look really happy,
actually, he might be having the time of his
life there, but we project on to him this
sense that you know, he's off, he's having
a bad night, he's by himself.
And I want us to remember this idea, too,
that we tend to project a lot onto the image
of the person who is alone.
Um, so he looks lonely.
But in a way and this is also important for
our story, the people across from him look
pretty lonely, too.
They are together but they don't seem to be
having a love connection.
Uh, you know, something is off.
And remember this idea.
Now 1943, it would make some sense to think
of people who are alone as being off in someway.
It was very unusual to live alone or even
to be single.
So what you're looking at here is just a simple
bar chart of the proportion of American adults
who were single in 1950 about 22% and also
the proportion of American households that
had just one person, under 10%.
OK, this is 1950.
So maybe that kind of atmosphere, the mood
you get in the hopper painting makes some
sense given the time.
You should know also that peoples views about
those who lived alone were in keeping with
this kind of story.
When some psychologists at the university
of Michigan did a survey of American's attitudes
towards people who lived alone and were single
they found that 80% of American adults thought
that single people were either sick or neurotic
or immoral if they wanted to be single.
It was just a very weird thing to be doing
then and we were quite judgmental about it.
I'm a social scientist and let me say that
my discipline has contributed to this idea.
The best selling books in the history of American
sociology have titles like The Lonely Crowd,
The Fall of Public Man.
More recent titles that maybe you've seen,
Bowling Alone; do you remember this concept
of bowling alone?
Uh, Robert Putnam's great book from about
12 years ago.
And more recently Sherry Turkle an MIT professor,
Alone Together about the ways in which technology
including social media, --maybe especially
social media-- in her view, estrange us from
one another.
This has been a long-standing concern of American
life.
If any of you are subscribers to the Atlantic
Monthly, you'll know that their current cover
story asks the question 'Is Facebook Making
Us Lonely?'
And the author claims that, in fact, we are
experiencing an epidemic of loneliness in
the United States.
We have never been lonelier or more atomized
he claims.
We hear ideas like this quite often.
Uh, about six years ago, a blockbuster study
came out in the American Sociological Review,
the kind of premier journal in my discipline,
and it reported that we've never been more
isolated.
One in four Americans, it claimed, said that
they have no confidant, no close friend, no
one with whom they can discuss important confidential
personal matters.
And that was an incredible spike from 1985
when, uh, when it was just under 1 in 10 in
fact.
So what really changed between 1984 and 1985
and 2004, well, the internet.
So a lot of people thought well maybe this
is a story about the internet.
This is a story we are used to telling ourselves.
Let me also confess, my first book is about
a heat wave in Chicago was for many people
powerful because it reported on hundreds of
people dying alone in the city of Chicago
and the book is kind of thought to be in that
tradition of, you know, stories about how
isolated and estranged we've become in the
united states.
So I am, I have contributed to this concept
myself, you know, full disclosure.
When I finished the reporting for Heat Wave
and the research for Heat Wave, I decided
I was going to do a bigger project, on this
issue of living alone and being alone in American
cities.
I thought something important was happening
and I expected that what was important was
that we were getting estranged.
I thought I would write the book I told you
the title of, Alone in America.
But the first thing I did is I pulled out
of the story of Chicago was principally the
people I studied were older and frail and
poor and I wanted to see, you know, who really
does live alone in the United States.
So I want to direct you for the moment towards
the bottom of this chart, where you get the
distribution of living alone by age.
Now this was a surprise to me.
OK, it turns out that today, about 32.7 million
Americans live alone.
OK that's up from the 4 million in 1950.
Uh, 9% of all households.
I thought they'd be mostly elderly, but the
truth is about a third of people who live
alone today are over the age of 65 and I'm
reluctant even to call them elderly, because
part of the story is that people are staying
younger for longer and more active and engaged
in the world as they hit their sixties and
seventies.
About half of the people who live alone in
the United states today are middle aged adults
between the ages of 35 and 64.
Typically the have lived with someone else
before, generally they have been married and
they're now separated or divorced.
Um, but they're not the people I studied when
I did the book about Chicago.
And then, this is a surprise to me before
I stated, by far the fastest growing segment
of American's who live alone in the last several
decades has been young adults under the age
of 35 about 500 thousand young adults lived
alone in 1950 and today more than 5 million
do.
They represent about 11% of all young adults.
And so if you think about this change from
1950, it really is quite staggering and this
is you know what earns for me the first claim
I gave you that this is the biggest social
change we haven't named or identified.
Look at the dramatic spike in the number of
people who are unmarried, single, today it's
about half of all adults and then next to
it, the proportion of households that have
just one person.
You know from 9% in 1950 to 28% today.
This is a striking demographic shift and one
that has far-reaching implications.
So I just want to give you a little bit more
of the numbers.
I'm guessing you'd be curious, you can see
what this looks like in terms of the sheer
population.
From 1960 to today.
You can look at it at the proportion of households,
pretty similar slope.
I told you that in 1950 living alone was most
common in this big sprawling western states
and rural areas, the Lone Ranger was our figure.
Well, by today, it has become an overwhelmingly
urban phenomenon.
And not just one in the you know, kind of
fancy elite coastal cities, you might not
be surprised that 42% of households are one
person households in Seattle or 40% in San
Francisco, you know, near the mother ship.
But look at Denver and Minneapolis and Atlanta,
you know, all above 40%.
Washington DC, 48%, Manhattan now 46%, you
know almost one in every two households.
So this is really that, it's really become
something that we do in cities and that's
striking.
What I want to do for the remainder of my
talk is kind of move beyond these numbers
though and get you kind of inside the story
of my research and tell you more about what
I learned and what this means.
The the work for this project, uh, involved
getting the numbers right up front, but then
also doing hundreds of interviews with people
who live alone in different cities around
the United states, mainly cities in this research
and a little bit outside of the United States
as well.
And we did research with people who fall into
the three different age groups I gave you
before.
And then also and I won't talk about it much
today, uh, with a smaller sample of pretty
poor men who live alone in hotel residences.
It's a declining group in many respects, but
numerically as well.
One of the big conceptual changes for me in
doing this book came from thinking about living
alone as a social problem, which is what generally
attracts the interest of sociologists, you
know something we perceive to be a problem
in the world, to thinking about it as a social
experiment, which is more unusual.
And why did I see it that way?
Well, one of the things I learned doing a
lot of reading in history and anthropology
is that until about the 1950s you cannot find
a single human society in the history of our
species that sustained large numbers of people
living alone for long periods of time.
It literally does not exist and this is a
little passage from one of the classic books
in anthropology uh George Murdock on social
structure where he makes the claim that the
nuclear family is a universal.
And he was challenged, but generally from
people who said 'you know what about the kibbutz
or what about this more communal arrangement?'
No one challenged him and said 'look at this
society where large numbers of people organized
their personal lives by living alone' It's
a novel experience and this we misunderstand
it if we see it only as a social problem.
So how did it happen?
How did we make this sudden break?
This innovation in the way we organize our
lives and how should we think about it?
Well, the first thing to say is it's expensive
to live alone and one reason you see the spike
in living alone after the 1950s is we have
more widespread affluence.
It's a tough thing to say in a moment like
this when the economy's not doing so well,
but the period after World War II is a beginning
of a period of real affluence in many developed
economies.
Uh, some of the wealth comes from the market
economy, but much of the security that we've
earned since then comes too from the contributions
to the welfare state and when you have Social
Security and guaranteed health care and home
care and public transportation and all the
things we now in some ways take for granted
as part of the welfare estate it becomes much
easier to live independently and get the kinds
of services and support you need from institutions
that are not the family, sharing a home with
you.
And when you recognize that living alone is
a feature of an affluent society, you flip
the question from social problem to this one:
Of all the ways that we could use our resources,
you know, why this?
You know, what does this say?
You know it's not, this is not an easy question
to answer.
But it's important to ask the question in
this way.
Well, one of the things that's clear is that
living alone comports with a number of our
sacred modern values, right?
It gives us a level of freedom to do what
we want, when we want to do it.
Uh, it allows us to achieve a level of personal
control that can be very difficult, uh, when
we share space with another person.
When we have that space, we have a chance
for a level of self-realization, uh, for young
people and I'll talk about this a little later,
many of the younger adults who live alone
say that they do it so that they can become
adult.
So that they have the time and space to think
about who they are and the kind of life they
want to live, the kind of person they want
to become.
Now that we marry later than ever before,
which we do, the typical age of first marriage
in the United States is about 29 for men and
about 27 for women, uh, it's by getting a
place of their own that young adults have
this experience of feeling like they are becoming
themselves.
And I'll say something else about this which
is that, people who live alone longer and
delay getting married as opposed to getting
married in their early 20s are much more likely
to marry successfully, to stay married than
people who race into it.
So that's why I say living alone gives people
the, not just the chance for solitude, this
kind of productive solitude that probably
all of us need and a hyper networked age like
the one we live in now.
But also because living alone paradoxically
gives us a chance to reconnect.
And to connect in perhaps on a deeper level
with the kinds of people we're really looking
for.
OK
In the book, I argue that they're four big
drivers in the spike of living alone in addition
to prosperity, uh, the first is not Mary Tyler
Moore, but it is the rising status of women
in the world.
You simply can't understand why, that so many
people live alone outside of this.
Um, when women enter into the paid labor force
en masse in the beginning of the 1950s, um,
they established the economic independence
to live longer without getting married, you
know, on their own and they also give themselves
a chance to get out of a bad relationship
or marriage without sentencing themselves
to a lifetime of poverty or forcing, uh, their
family to take them in.
It was actually quite common sixty, seventy,
eighty years ago for a woman for whatever
reason lost her husband, or separated her
husband to move back in with her family.
Um, and when women become economically independent
they no longer have to do that.
Of course, women also become more culturally
independent in the post war period, as well.
Uh and gain a control over their own bodies
that they didn't have before.
The sexual revolution is part of this.
You can't understand the spike in living alone
outside of it, we notice, I'll just tell you
one place where there is a lot of affluence,
but almost no one lives alone and that's Saudi
Arabia.
In parts of the world where women don't have
this level of independence, living alone is
impossible.
Now here we are at Google and it would be
silly for me not to emphasize that you can't
really understand the rise of living alone
outside of communications technologies.
Now admittedly the spike starts in living
alone starts earlier, you saw that on the
charts I showed before.
Um, but it's not as if there was not communication
technology, there.
When you have the telephone and the television
set, then it, you can be home alone and also
connected to ideas and people and information
and entertainment in a way that was previously
impossible.
Now think about what it means to live alone
and be home alone when you have Skype and
Facebook and Google + and instant messaging
and Meetup and Craigslist and all the kinds
of technologies that we have that connect
us to each other.
Right it means that living alone and being
home alone can be a profoundly social experience
and I want to make something clear here, you
know, we are at this moment, remember that
Facebook cover story, is Facebook making us
lonely, the Atlantic Monthly has right now,
there is a lot of anxiety that social media
has made us less connected, less deeply connected.
But the best research in the social sciences
we have tells us that the heaviest users of
social media are also the heaviest users of
face-to-face interaction.
Heavy users of social media are actually more
likely to spend time in public and to spend
face time with friends and neighbors than
the lighter users.
OK?
So a lot of our anxiety is maybe about the
quality of those connections or maybe about
our distraction, there's lots of reasons to
be concerned about where our attention is
in a digital age.
But there's no evidence that it's making us
less connected to each other.
I showed you that map of American cities that
have high proportions of one-person households.
That's also part of the big story here.
You can't understand the rise of living alone
outside of urbanization.
Cities are places where people can live alone
and be together with others who are like them.
So if I tell you that in Manhattan about one
of every two households is a one person households,
as people who live here or at least come to
work here everyday, you know that there's
certain neighborhoods where there far more
single people and people who live alone than
others.
So in places like Chelsea and the West Village
and Midtown, 60 70% of the households are
one person households and I bet if I say the
names of Los Angeles or Chicago or Seattle
or San Fransisco or Boston to you you know
precisely which neighborhoods in those cities
are concentrations are places where people
who live alone are concentrated.
And of course, people who are single or live
alone, and I make a distinction between the
two, they are different things.
They are attracted to those places.
So we have cities have become places that
have transformed the experience of being alone.
Moreover, and I wrote an article for Fortune
magazine about this recently, I don't think
you can understand the renaissance of public
life in cities and in urban economies outside
of the rise of single people and people who
live alone inside of them.
Because they are very active.
There's also a myth about people who live
alone, that they are isolated and more lonely,
right?
They, the people in the Edward Hopper paintings.
But another thing I learned, writing this
book, is that on average people who live alone
are actually more likely to spend time with
friends and with neighbors than people who
are married.
It's not going to surprise you learn that
they're more likely to go out at night and
spend time and money in bars and restaurants
and cafes, you know I'm not going to win a
Nobel prize for that discovery.
Um, but they're also more likely to volunteer
in civic organizations, on average, than people
who are married.
And that really was a surprise to me, we have
a story we tell ourselves about the way in
which married people and families are the
bedrocks of community life.
And that's true in some respects but it's
not true in all respects.
And, of course, the, you know the people who
specifically do more time with friends and
neighbors and who contribute more to civic
organizations when they're single or living
alone are women.
Because married women when they have children,
especially, just don't have the time and the
energy to contribute to public life in the
same way, they are generally saddled with
more domestic responsibilities.
Not to demean that, you know and I should
be really clear, I'm not here to persuade
you to go home and leave your wife or your
husband, you know, this is not the case to
live alone.
It would be hypocritical for me to do that.
I'm married myself, I have two young kids.
But this is something that we need to understand
and I think we need to reexamine our attitudes
and kind of, premises about what it means
to live alone and what people who live alone
do.
Now the fourth, you know, generator of the
spike in living alone is the longevity revolution.
Today we live longer than ever before, but
we live unevenly.
You can't know a certainty that you and your
spouse will live together and die the same
day or week or year and in fact, it is now
become quite common for women, who tend to
outlive men, to outlive their spouse by two
or five or ten or in some cases, you know,
twenty or twenty five years.
And you can probably think of people in your
friendship circle or in your family who have
lived alone for long periods of time at this
stage of life.
Right?
And this is where the Ed Hopper paintings,
you know, really become resonant again.
Uh, when you're old, you're more at risk of
getting isolated and withdrawn, that's why
so many older people died alone in the heat
wave.
Now I have to tell you that I was amazed to
learn that from the best survey research that
older Americans, too, are more likely to spend
time with friends and neighbors if they live
alone than they are if they're married.
I really didn't expect that.
Um, so we shouldn't think that universally
they're isolated and lonely, but there is
a risk here.
And, you know, there's a gendered risk as
well, I should say.
Women are far more likely to age alone, but
they're also better at staying connected to
friends and family than men, so they tend
to be less isolated.
Whereas men who live alone especially men
who age alone tend to fare worse.
I put this slide up here because maybe that
will change.
You know maybe the way that we connect with
each other provides opportunities for everyone
who lives alone to establish connect-, you
know, relationships and to be together in
new ways.
We know all the ways in which young people
use social media to make ties and to organize
face-to-face time as well.
You surely know that increasingly older people
are getting online and using social media
for in the same ways, right?
So maybe if you have children, your children
talk to their grandparents with Skype.
Uh, you know mine do and that's a big change.
But there are other ways in which older people
are connecting with each other and with other
neighbors, with people they don't know, through
dating sites, through friendship sites, with
things like Meetup online as well.
So there's a whole arena in which social media
and communications technologies become really
important to thinking about how we will live
together, now that we're living alone.
I don't mean to be telling you in this you
know, talk today, that we shouldn't be worried
about loneliness.
Obviously many people who live alone suffer
from loneliness and it can be difficult to
be alone and live alone and be lonely, because
it can quickly cycle into a vicious cycle.
Right?
Each one feeds the other, but lets be realistic
about loneliness and what it means in the
human condition, as well.
Because this is something people told me over
and over again in my interviews.
People worry about us when we live alone,
but they also say that, there's nothing lonelier
than being in the wrong relationship.
It means something to feel lonely when you're
sitting at home in your apartment, you know
you get a cue physiologically, emotionally
to get out into the world and engage with
other people.
But if you're lying next to your spouse and
you feel lonely, that's a really powerful
cue and it's not quite clear what you can
do with that.
It's profound and intense.
Remember that study I showed you in the beginning
of the, the talk, the one in four American's
have no confidant?
It, I put this up, you know with the, um,
image because the images from USA Today and
when that study came out in 2006, it got enormous
amounts of attention, it's as if we have an
appetite to be told that we're isolated from
each other.
The authors were on every TV show imaginable.
They got amazing coverage in the USA Today
and the New York Times.
Well, it turns out the data were flawed.
Many of us suspected this at the time, not
that it was easy for us to get airtime on
those TV shows, reporting that you know, we
don't have friends anymore.
Um, but now the data has really been heavily
scrutinized and the guy who's now a professor
at Cornell, who was a grad student who crunched
the numbers.
You guys know about grad students who crunch
numbers here.
He's, he's, you know, now publicly said, you
know this is not reliable.
And it isn't.
Uh, we're not more isolated than ever before,
we're just about as isolated as we always
have been.
You know, we're not more lonely than we have
before.
I took on the Facebook cover story in an article
in Slate.
We're about as lonely as we have been.
Right?
And that doesn't mean we shouldn't be concerned
about some things.
There's lots of reasons to make our lives
better and to strive for more connection and
less loneliness but let's not panic, um, let's
not panic about this.
I told you before that my, um, book was going
to be called Alone In America and I've now
spent about 40 minutes telling you why the
alone part of the book title was wrong.
That was a really bad idea.
People who live alone are not so alone.
This slide tells you that how bad the 'in
America' part of my title was.
I really thought this was going to be a thing
about you know American individualism and
our culture of, you know, self-reliance.
Right?
Emerson and Thoreau and the Lone Ranger and
the whole thing and that turns out to just
be wrong.
Um, or to the extent that Americans have those
kinds of cultural attitudes, we're just like
people in many other countries.
Uh, including Japan, Canada, the Scandinavian
nations, most of Europe.
What's striking is, in fact, the places on
Earth that have the highest proportion of
people living alone are the Scandinavian countries
which make the greatest contributions to the
welfare state.
Right?
And what I came away understanding, which
I really didn't know when I started the project,
is that it's by contributing to the common
good and to these commonly shared resources
that we give ourselves the capacity to live
the way that feels best.
Which is to say that it's our interdependence
that makes our independence possible.
It's our interdependence that makes our independence
possible, that's why living alone is so much
higher in countries with generous welfare
states.
It's also why living alone is so much higher
in cities than it is in rural areas.
Now very few people aspire to live alone,
most Americans, most people will get married
at some point in their lives.
My point is not, you know, this is what we
want most in life.
But what's different about us today is that
we recognize that if we can't find the relationship
that works for us, we can live alone and be
pretty social.
You know, we can live alone and be better
than we thought we would be, even better than,
you know, our aunt, or you know, our grandmother
or our friends think we're going to be.
Because remember the guy in the Hopper painting
whose back is to us and we project our feelings
on to him?
It turns out we often do this with people
we know in our own lives who are single and
aren't married, the first thing we talk to
them about it whether they've met someone
and can we fix them up.
Sometimes that's the right thing to do but
sometimes it's not.
So I hope you understand, you know, now, why
Going Solo and not Alone in America is the
title for this book.
And I hope you see that, you know the birds
take you some place where you know the Ed
Hopper paintings don't.
And you know maybe when the paperback comes
out we'll come up with a human image that,
you know, suits this story.
But I hope that over lunch today I've at least
given you something to think about.
So thank you very much, it's been a pleasure
talking to you.
[Applause]
>> Eric: So I think we have some time for
questions.
>> Male #1: You said that, um, basically that
the level of dysfunction is essentially constant
as a society has it moved around, I mean if
the most, you seem to say the most functional
people are actually getting better.
Are the least functional people getting worse?
>> Eric: That's a good question.
To be honest, I don't have the data to really
answer that question.
But I do think that the we are providing less
to people who have the most trouble.
And this is worrisome.
So for instance, you know, when there is an
economic crisis and cities lose their funding
to do a bunch of different programs, uh, they
often do things like, cut the budget for senior
care, or for specialized transportation.
Maybe you've followed this debate in New York
City the last several years, I write about
it in the book, where the city is actually
quite generous with programs for older people
and older people who live alone.
And one of the great programs the city has
maintained over the years has been a Meals
on Wheels program.
You know, you get a hot meal delivered to
your door everyday if you're in need.
Well, when times got tough and the agencies
lost funding, they said 'we've got to economize.'
And one really nice way to do that is to deliver
more meals, you know, per visit, so rather
than a live human being coming to knock on
your door and hand you a meal and provide
a little company everyday, you might get six
frozen meals twice a week.
Now that's a cold policy and I'm not talking
about the food.
You know, it's a policy that fails to register
the way in which the interaction is part of
what you're giving when you give a meal.
That's happening in an affluent city like
New York City.
Cities around the country are cutting far
more than that.
And so I worry that people who live alone
and are really vulnerable and isolated are
getting more vulnerable and more isolated.
That really was the story of the heat wave
in Chicago.
It's an invisible world in some respects.
One guy I spoke with called this a secret
society of people who live and die alone.
We certainly don't see it in our everyday
lives.
But it's a real world and one I think we should
be concerned about.
One of the things that I'm trying to think
out now is, you know, what are the implications
of the aging of the boomer generation for
aging alone?
We are going to have record numbers of people
who are old and living alone.
Many of them had their savings you know, clipped
quite a lot, uh, by the recession and the
crash in the stock market in 2008 and I fear
that we haven't figured out a way to provide
the kind of care and support to older people
who are alone, uh, that we really need to
do.
In my family we, you know, my grandmother
who died recently, uh, needed to be in an
assisted living facility and she was fortunate
enough to have you know three children who
could help to take care of her, uh and support
her.
But it was incredibly expensive and she lived
that way for a long time, more than a decade,
uh and there are not a lot of families that
can sustain that.
So I think we'll collectively need to find
some way to deal with this housing issue for
older people for sure.
Yeah.
>> male #2: Um, I'll throw out a couple of
comments and questions.
There seems to me that there's an underlying
subtext here in your talk at least, I haven't
read your book.
That alone is wrong, that alone is bad.
Um, and, you know, you seem to be a little
surprised that that's not always the case.
And you know I don't think it seems to me
that's perhaps the reflection of a classic
sort of approach of an extrovert to people
who are more introverted, not everyone finds
spending, you know the most productive they
can be, or the most happy they can be is spending,
you know, is being out in a bar, at a party
with a lot of people and talking.
I mean a lot of us find, I don't know about
a lot of us, the world, but certainly a lot
of us Google engineers, a ridiculously large
percentage of Google engineers find it exactly
the opposite that there's, um, a real value
to being alone, or solo, at least some of
the time.
And specifically to point out one thing you
sort of threw out there.
I think you made a comment, if I heard you
correctly that you know, you don't win Nobel
prizes by going out to bars.
>> Eric: No no, my that my claim to you, that
people who live alone tend to go out more
was not going to win me a Nobel prize.
>> Male 2: Oh, I'm sorry, then I completely
misunderstood that claim.
>> Eric: Neither of us gets a Nobel today.
Next, next week.
OK, can I say something about this?
Because, I think what you've hit on is totally
right.
What I hope came across today and what I learned
in the book is my prior was that, you know,
people who live alone, whether they're introverted
or not were less connected and that this is
something we needed to really worry about
because they could dangerously isolated.
And they were lonely people and they were
miserable living alone, I shared in that quite
widespread view.
And what I learned in the course of doing
this work is, I think, your prior, some of
us need to learn a lot before we get someone
else's prior.
Which is that in fact for many people living
alone, being alone, spending time alone works
out pretty well.
Much better than we conventionally think.
That's why I think we need to break away from
the concept that this a social problem, only,
and also recognize it as a social experiment.
Now there is a difference between being alone
and spending a lot of work time alone.
I'm a writer, most writers have the same thing
as, you know, Google engineers, we need to
have our time with our machine.
Uh, but that's different from living alone.
And what's really interesting to me sociological,
anthropologically, you know, historically
is that we never did this before.
You know, we are involved in an experiment
that really is unprecedented and, I think,
you know, my book might be the first of this
social experiment but surely there will be
more, because this is a whole scale re-engineering
of what it means to organize your life, your
home, um, we don't have stories to tell about
it, there's not a great you know, there's
not received wisdom from centuries.
There's the herme-, the tradition of hermits
and monks, but there's not much that understands
what it means to live alone in an urban environment.
And, you know, my book the book is really
my first cut at this, but I think this is
something we'll be mulling over for a long
time.
And I think that people in places like Google
will be playing in a role, playing a role
in this because a lot of what shapes the quality
of your experience, uh, is your interaction
with screens and with the social life that
the digital culture affords.
Um, I hope you share that view.
Yeah.
>> male #3: If this trend of the people living
alone goes on for a long time, what are the
long-term implications of that would be on
the society on a larger scale?
Um, for example, I consider families as a
top of a social safety net that's more reliable
than lets say your mutual fund.
>> Eric: Yeah.
So, there are many questions to consider here.
Um, recall that in Scandinavia where living
alone is far more advanced than what it is
here.
In Stockholm, for instance, about 60% of the
households are one-person households.
47% of households at the national level in
Sweden are one-person households, so we can
see a little bit of our future in Scandinavia,
but that's if we sustained social programs
and support services and a welfare state to
the level that they do there and that seems
unlikely at a moment like this.
It even seems unlikely there.
So that's to say that you can sustain living
alone as an experience and also sustain good
health and longevity if you make the commitment
to the public institutions that can do that.
That's the, I'd say that's what we can learn
from the Scandinavians.
If you don't do, that and you kind of privatize
it and marketize it, than you run the risk
of real isolation.
Because those who can't sustain themselves
will fall through the cracks.
For my money, the real question about sustainability
has to do with the environment.
You know, what does it mean to have so many
people with their own individual, you know,
kitchens and other appliances and homes?
Now, we don't have enough research to really
answer that question, so it's not at all clear
to me that the carbon footprint of four single
people living in small energy efficient Manhattan
apartments who use public transportation to
get to work is any bigger than the carbon
footprint than the family of four in a West
Chester 3000 square foot home with you know
two cars and long commutes.
What's the right comparison to answer this
kind of question, you know?
I don't know.
Because living alone is an urban experience
mostly these days and because cities are places
where we can really build a more ecologically
sustainable future, I don't think it's definitely
going to be a problem, but I think this is
something we really need to watch and develop.
Yeah.
>> male #4: Going back to the introvert point,
um, I'm not sure if introverts have anything
to do with this but, did you find in your
research that any specific personality traits
tend to much more willingly want to live alone,
uh, than others, or is it sort of like equal
opportunity for all sorts of circumstances
in life?
>> Eric: So I have to say that, not being
a psychologist I wasn't asking questions about
personality types so what I have to say next
reflects my kind of off the cuff thinking
rather than careful systematic observation.
Um, uh, clearly um, people who are prone to
depression and feelings of loneliness struggle
more when they're on their own than others.
And there is, you know, this you know vicious
circle, sort of vicious cycle, where the loneliness
feeds the depression which leads to you know
withdrawing from social life which makes you
more lonely and depressed and that can be
a real problem.
If you have that set of personality characteristics
and you know that then living alone will be
a challenge.
Living alone requires, you know, learning
and developing a specific set of skills and
one of those skills is to get yourself out
into the world when it feels like the world
isn't making a place for you.
One woman I interviewed talked about getting
her own place after you know living with roommates,
um.
This is real sign of success and distinction
in a city, right?
You move to Manhattan you have to go to school,
you get your first job and you live with roommates,
but then you can't stand your roommates after
a while so you get your own place and that
means you really made it and, um, and then
she said "So, I got my own place and I was
so excited and I kept thinking this was going
to be like college where the phone would ring
or someone would come knocking on the door
and say ''hey come on we're all going out''
but that doesn't happen.
You know that, so you have to figure out a
way to project yourself into the world and
if you know you can't do that, you know, you
either have to learn that skill and she did,
you know, or you have to look for some other
kind of arrangement.
I think it's notable, too, um, this is not
a psychological trait so much as a social
one, uh, that men tend to fare worse when
they're living alone.
Um, women, not universally, but on average
just have better skills at making and maintaining
relationships, that's with their family members
and also with their friends and that's true
over the life course.
Um, maybe with social media, you know, men
have, you know younger generations are learning
new skills to connect with each other, you
know, maybe social media will provide that.
I don't know, I think it's too early to tell.
Um, I'm trying to look more carefully at it.
Uh, but clearly living alone is not for everyone.
[Silence]
>> Eric: Yeah, sorry.
>> female #1: Um, just wondering [inaudible]about
how in the 50s people thought of people living
alone is immoral and neurotic, did you find
any research on how people view people living
alone today?
>> Eric: It's a great question and basically,
uh, our attitudes have changed so much that
social scientists don't even ask the question.
You know, when you live in a moment where
half the adult population is single, you know,
and a third of them live alone, you know,
those asking those questions just feels funny.
Someone should, I mean I went back to the,
you know, the people who did the survey and
to the a lot of the people who do survey research
on attitudes towards marriage and I tried
to get this data and I couldn't do it.
Um, maybe someone will.
Alright, well, thank-you very much.
I really enjoyed speaking with you.
[Applause]